we cover corruption and the corporate
lobbying sort of industrial complex on
the program we also talk about two
justice systems on the program quite a
bit and we've also talked about the
emoluments clause which forbids the
president from getting things of value
from foreign governments and one of the
things that foreign governments have
been doing to ingratiate themselves with
Donald Trump
is when they go to DC on official
business they opt to stay at Trump
somewhat new hotel in Washington DC
which is just a few blocks down the road
down Pennsylvania Avenue from the White
House arguably that would be a violation
of the emoluments clause from trumps
perspective because these are foreign
individuals who are coming to the u.s.
to lobby the Trump administration for
things and they are giving Donald Trump
personally something of value naming
namely their dollars through his
for-profit hotel in Washington DC this
has included Kuwaiti and Filipino
embassy staff this has included Saudi
Arabian lobbyists this has included
holding a large oil industry group
meeting at Trump's hotel it's a pretty
long list and now we have a domestic
example of staying at Trump's hotels to
curry favor with him last April there
was a big merger announcement t-mobile
wanted to merge with Sprint it was going
to be a twenty six billion dollar merger
it would double t-mobile's value it
would very much increase the market
share of t-mobile but that was a merger
that needed Trump administration
approval we've now learned that the next
day after the announcement of that
merger plan t-mobile executives booked
rooms at Donald Trump's Washington hotel
the Trump International Hotel and
they've been staying there regularly
since by June of 2018
one executive had stayed at Trump's
hotel 10 times others had stayed close
to a handful of times often wearing
their t-mobile gear in the hotel now of
course can you tie any specific quid pro
quo to this right can staying at a hotel
at 1,100 Pennsylvania Avenue influence
the people at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
it would be tough to find a specific
quid pro quo on that
but this is the type of conflict that
the Trump administration is just totally
riddled with it's kind of like a
pilgrimage right you want favorable
rulings or influence or commentary from
the Trump administration first thing you
do is you reserve some Suites at Trump's
hotel a couple of blocks down the road
from the White House and patronizing
Donald Trump's private business is now
sort of a proxy to influencing public
policy from this administration this
hotel is now the center of a bunch of
different problems you've got the
emoluments clause related to the foreign
dignitaries that stay there there's the
American executives staying there
presumably to curry some favor for
mergers and then there's the kind of
broader concern which is that the hotel
this particular hotel happens to be in a
federally owned building Donald Trump's
private business leases the building
from the federal government Trump also
happens to be the current President of
the United States so the president has a
private business from which he makes
money in a building which he rents from
the federal government which he runs and
it's important to be really transparent
this is not unique to the Trump
administration it's particularly bad
under the Trump administration but think
back to George W Bush and the Iraq war
using Halliburton to rebuild Iraq and
then of course they have Vice President
Dick Cheney who happened to have
previously been the CEO of Halliburton
involved in deciding that Halliburton
is going to be getting paid handsomely
for rebuilding Iraq that's just one
example and there are many as far as the
Trump Hotel games at some point in time
we might simply have said this is
bribery right this is just bribery
period remember when Jimmy Carter was
president he had to relinquish ownership
of his peanut farm in Georgia because
that could have maybe in some way have
been a problem look at how far we have
fallen since then that now we can't even
get 100% agreement that listen Trump in
this hotel that this is a major conflict
it's just flat-out a conflict it's a
conflict in terms of the emoluments
clause it's a
conflict in terms of Trump the private
person renting a building from the
federal government run by Trump the
president it's a conflict all the way
down and when we think back to Jimmy
Carter Pat and that peanut farm it
almost seems quaint the idea of him
getting rid of those interests because
it could be a conflict yeah and we knew
when Trump was elected that these sort
of problems would arise that we'd have
to find a way around this and the
simplest solution is for Trump to divest
from his business to put it into a blind
trust but of course he never got around
to doing that and I I don't know what
the other source of solutions you can
come up with are but he's not even going
to try to come up with them because he's
profiting off of this and this is
exactly what he wants yeah not only that
it wasn't even clear Donald Trump ever
knew what a blind trust was because when
he put that stack of papers and did that
big press conference and said it's all
going to get taken care of very very
soon there was no actual Indic
indication that he had even the
slightest idea what it meant to put your
businesses in a blind trust or whether
that even applied when the businesses
all have your name on them and you still
know that they exist one of the days
sponsors is privacy dot-com / Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter
because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time
it is all completely free all you have
to do is click the link under this video
to get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link